[موسيقى]
ام
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام
من قال ان العرب لا يؤثرون ب امريكا الم
تتعلم منهم فنون الشجب و التنديد
والاستنكار السخيفه
ماذا قدمت واشنطن للثوره السوريه غير
تصريحات الجوفاء المندده والمستنكره الم
يصبح الموقف الامريكي عاريا تماما بعد ان
وافق النظام على تسليم سلاحه الكيماوي
لماذا اختزل اوباما معاناه شعب تشرد نصفه
بمساله الكيماوي الا يبارك اوباما النازيه
الجديده المتمثله
بوحشيه النظام السوري اليس السكوت علامه
الرضا الم يكن الروس والامريكيون متفقين
في مجلس الامن على استخدام الفيتو لانقاذ
الاسد اليس من السخف ان يتوقع الشعب
السوري المساعده من امريكا التي تعتبر
نظام الاسد اكبر حامل لاسرائيل في المنطقه
لكن في المقابل الم تلعب وكانت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه دورا كبيرا في
اداره الثوره السوريه اليس الدعم الذي
يتلقاه الثوار السوريون من هنا وهناك جاء
بمباركه امريكيه الم يسحب اوباما الشرعيه
من الاسد قبل اكثر من عامين الم تكن
القوات الامريكيه على اهبه الاستعداد بدك
مواقع النظام لولا انه استسلم تماما
للتهديد الامريكي لماذا يريد البعض من
امريكا ان تضرب النظام السوري اذا كان قد
سلم سلاحه الاستراتيجي من مجرد عكسه
امريكيه كيف نتهم امريكا بمؤازره النظام
السوري وهي التي تعمل على اضعافه عسكريا
وتحاصره اقتصاديا اسئله اطرحها على الهواء
مباشره هنا في الاستوديو على المعارضه
السوريه دكتور كمال الاخواني وعبر الاقمار
الصناعيه علي الخبير في الشؤون الامريكيه
خليل نبدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل قدمت امريكا للثوره السوريه غير
الكلام المعسول صوت حوالي عشرين الفا
واحده وثلاثين فاصله سته نعم ثمانيه وستين
فاصله اربعه لا لو بدات بهذه النتيجه معك
اه مجدي خليل يعني الغالبيه العظمى من
المصوتين يعتقدون يعتقدون ان امريكا لم
تقدم للثوره السوريه الا التصريحات
الجوفاء والكلام الفارغ وقبل فتره كان
هناك تصويت لدينا في نفس هذا البرنامج
اكثر من ثمانين بالمائه من الشارع العربي
كانوا يتوقعون على الاقل يعني موقفا
امريكيا اقوى من الذي اتخذته بعد ان
استخدم النظام السوري الكيماوي ضد الاطفال
الى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام يعني لم تكن
باختصار لم تكن سمعه امريكا في الشارع
العربي في هذا الحديث كما هي الان الجميع
يسخر من اوباما الجميع يضحك على هذه
الاداره التعيسه التي ترى النازيه باسوء
باسوء انواعها ولا تفعل شيء ماذا تقول لهم
يعني منذ متى كانت امريكا محبوبه في
العالم العربي او في الشرق الاوسط او في
ما يسمى بالعالم الاسلامي او ما يسمى
بالعالم العربي يعني هي طول الوقت امريكا
اه اه مكروها دائما مهما فعلت اه هل شكرا
حد امريكا بعد ضرب وفيها بعد كوسوفو بعد
تحرير الكويت بعد ضربه صدام حسين كثيرون
الذين كانوا يناشدون اه الذين لا لم
يذكرها احد لم يذكر الذين يشكرون يشكرون
همسا والذين يلعنون ها الان علنا بل ان
الذين كانوا يتوسلون اليها ليل نهار في
العراق لاسقاط صدام
بعد سقوط واتجهوا الى ايران مباشره
وانضموا الى اه يعني ما اعداء امريكا
هل على سبيل المثال هل في قطر يشكرون
امريكا رغم ان اعداء كثر
قطر كثيرون ولكن يخشون فقط من قاعده
العديد وليس من حاملات الطائرات القطريه
يخشون من قاعده العديد الامريكيه ولولا
ذلك
لهب اعضاء قطر عليها فبالتالي اه هل هل
الف الجزيره تشكرون امريكا هل في قطر
يشكرون امريكا
انا اسالك سؤال محدد بدون ما تروح لي
يشكرون ما يشكرون انا اقول لك انه العالم
يقول الان يعني صحفي امريكي بشان اوباما
يقول ان الرئيس الامريكي الوحيد الذي لا
يخشى احد الرئيس الامريكي لا يخشى احد فرد
اخر قال اخشى ان الرئيس الامريكي الوحيد
الذي لا يحترمه احد امريكا تقول انها سيده
العالم انها كذا وكذا شرطي العالم شعب
يباد امام اعينها لا احد يريد منها ان
تقاتل نيابه عنه لا احد يريد منها اي شيء
فقط ان تضع حدا هي تقول قائده العالم اين
هي من السور من سوريا سوريا يعني كل في
الجمعيه العامه اليوم الرئيس التركي يقول
لم يشهد القرن العشرين ولا الواحده وعشرين
مجازر كما تشهد سوريا على ايدي هذا النظام
انا عم بسالك ماذا تقول لهم
طيب وماذا يريدون هو السؤال الاكثر وجهها
ماذا يريدون ان تقدم امريكا لهم ماذا
يريدون ان تقدم امريكا لهم والصراع اصلا
خارج خارج المصالح الامريكيه بخارج اي شيء
حتى خارج اللعبه الديمقراطيه
هل تتصور يا اخي فيصل ان الصراع في الشرق
الاوسط حاليا هو على شكل الاستبداد وليس
على شكل الديمقراطيه الرئيس التركي الذي
يتحدث عن هذا الكلام في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده تدعم دولته الارهابيين في
سوريا
الاحد ان تساعد امريكا مائه وثلاثين
ارهابي جايين من مرتزقه الجهاد الاسلامي
القادمون من نواحي الارض كلها لتخريب
سوريا وهؤلاء الناس الذين اه اه كانت
افعالهم البشع هؤلاء تريد ان امريكا
تساعدهم لكي تكون
القاعده جديده في سوريا بدل من افغانستان
المشهد في سوريا حاليا مشهد افغاني كيف
تساعد في تساعد من امريكا في هذا المشهد
العام امريكا تركت القياده اوباما التتبع
قاعده اسمها القياده من الخلف
وترك حلفائه لكي يقودون بمساعدته ومساعدات
امريكا ولكن الذي المشهد الذي تراه في
سوريا هو من صنع حلفاء امريكا من صنع
اردوغان والمحور الاخواني المحور الاخواني
الذي قضوا اردوغان
سياتي الى نقطه الاسلاميين يعني باختصار
شديد امريكا لا تريد ان تساعد ارهابيين
باختصار اه دكتور سمعت هذا الكلام ماذا
تريدون من امريكا السؤال الذي يطرحه
الكثيرون الان اذا كنتم فورا فعلا وتريدون
ثوره وتريدون تغييرا لماذا تذهبون الى
امريكا لماذا تذهبون الى مجلس الامن طب
اذا مش قادر ان تعمل والثوره ل يستعملوها
بالاصل ليش بتعملوا ثوره بعد يطرحوا
الامريكي اول شيء نحنا قطعان صوره بناءنا
منشوره امريكا داعيه عفويه بسوريه قام
فيها شعب بدون ان يشعر احد حتى ما شاور
السياسيه وانت بتعرف هذا الكلام بس انا
ارد على الاخ بامريكا انه ما فعله اوباما
اوباما قال انه الرئيس السوري غير شرعيه
وقت لاطلاق النار هذا الشعب فجاه الرئيس
السوري صار شرعي بعدما استخدم الكيماوي
يعني صار شرعي يعني بعد ما ان تستخدم
الكيماوي ضد شعبه ارتكب جريمه هولوكوست ضد
شعب ترجع شرعيتك انا ما تفهم على على
الالوان الالوان الحمر يعني من يتجاوز
الخطوط الحمر لاوباما يستعيد شرعيته هذا
كلام خطير يعني
يعني
شريك في صنع السلام بدي اخذه على جنيف
بدنا نقعد نحنا بدو يسلم الكيماويه
وبالتالي صار تحارب الارهاب
بدانا نشكل نحنا وياه حكومه مشتركه لا
نحارب الارهاب من يعني الارهاب شو بدو شو
بالارهاب يعني بيسدوا انه سوريا صارت
الساحه فارغه استغل اربع خمسه الاف واحد
ويحاولوا اجنداتهم وهني على الارض لان
حاضنه اجتماعيه ولا لمستقبل بسوريا هلا
انا بدي اختصار الشعب السوري بشويه ناس
تسللوا ونتيجه الفوضى هذا الكلام صحيح هذا
الكلام مو صح هذا الكلام و مضبوط الشعب
السوري كلنا ستعرف الشعب السوري لانس
حاضنه للارهاب لم يكن ولن يكون ولن يكون
لا هلا ولا بعدين وبالتالي هذا الاتهام
مردود مردود انا اللي شفته ان المجتمع
الدولي ترك القضيه كلها
الى مكان اخر من امريكا بالذات تركت
المذبحه تركت الشعب الذي يذبح وراحت لحتى
اه ت تعمل اتفاق معاهده اه معاهده تسليم
الاسلحه وكانه اذا تسلمها سلاح انحلت
المشكله هذا السلاح لن يسلم سيقسم منه
وسيهرب قسمان قسم من وبالتالي الخطر قائم
وهني
امريكا في غباء مو معقول على الاطلاق في
جنون في جنون الجنون بجنون بالسياسه جنوب
العقل العقل الذي يفكر ما هي الرساله التي
وجهها الى الشعب السوري قال انتوا فين
قضيه كما تهمني اذا بتموتوا معليش اه
رساله الحقد والكراهيه للشعب السوري
بيهمني انا حتى هو عم بيخاطب الاعلام
الامريكي وقت اللي قال انا بدي بدي اضرب
سؤال
مين حلفاؤه يعني
الرساله اللي قالها الامريكيين خلونا انا
ما راح يعني انا مش بس اخلاقي انا لا
اخلاقي رايح اخدم مصالحه انا مش رايح يحمي
مدنيين ولا اطفال ونساء دول لا شيء
بالنسبه لي بالنسبه الى حلفاء في المنطقه
يعني اسرائيلي مع معناها وفي النهايه وقت
الحق مصالح اسرائيل ووقف نسي انه في شعب
اباد ننسى انه في مائتين الف عيد نسي في
ملايين المشردين كل هذه القضيه الانسانيه
لا تعني امريكا هل امريكا بهذا الشكل اي
دوله عظمى هل امريكا بهذا الشكل الدوله
تستحق ان تكون مسؤوله عن الامن بالعالم مع
هذا الجنين بتقول المتضرر من السلاح
المحرم دوليا له حق استخدام قوه الغير
يعني وين رحت من مسؤوليات كلمتي تلتزم
امريكا بمسؤولياتها تصبح دوله دوله عظمى
امريكا معطله العالم معطل النظام العالمي
هي وروسيا اذن من المسؤول عن الامن في
العالم اليوم هو الذي يخرب الامن هذه
الرساله هي رساله همجيه هي رساله حداعش
الباب شي ما فيه شيء بشر حداعش هذه
الرساله الحقيقه على الشعب السوري رساله
الرساله العمليه الامريكيه والروسيه ايضا
هي التي تشرع من التطرف وانا بعيد السؤال
على صديقنا انه ما هو سبب التطرف اليس هو
غطرسه القوى اليس هو القفز فوق العداله
اليس هو اعفاء المجرم من جريمته ان الناس
ان تتخلى الناس التطرف عندما نصبح سنتين
سنه سنتين ونص ولا احد يدري يعني انا بقول
لك شغله شغله بسيطه لو قصفت حديقه حيوان
بالمدفعيه كان العالم كله ما تخص فسوريا
تقصد دمشق ولا حدا بيقول حتى الدول
العربيه ودول الخليج
الامريكي العربيه مش موضوعنا خلينا في
امريكا مش خليل كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
انت تعلم ان الرئيس الامريكي اوباما سحب
الشرعيه من الرئيس السوري قبل اكثر من
سنتين في اغسطس 2011 اه ودائما يقول فقد
شرعيته فقد شرعيته عليها التنحي فجاه ياتي
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ويتصل بوزير
الخارجيه السوري المعلم يعني فتح خط فورا
لماذا حدث ذلك حدث ذلك بعد ان استخدم
النظام الكبرى ويقول لك الدكتور هون يعني
ال بشار الاسد طلب الى شرعيه على مدى
سنتين حتى تجاوز الخط الاحمر فاصبح شرعيا
مثل نقطه كيف ترد
اولا الرئيس الامريكي اوباما اليوم امام
الامم المتحده قال ان بشار الاسد فقد
شرعيته
فبالتالي كيف تقول انه اه عاد الى اعاده
اليه الشرعيه قال امام الامم المتحده الذي
ضرب شعبه بالكيماوي هو شخص ليس له شرعيه
وبالتالي مساله الشرعيه امريكا او من قبل
حتى تثور وهي ترى ان ن نظام بشار الاسد
لابد ان يسقط خليني انا بقول لك وجهه
النظر الامريكيه منذ الفين وثلاثه كان
عايزين يسقطوا صدام كان بعد سقوط صدام
ضرب صدام كان عاوزين كانوا المحافظون
الجدد كانوا عاوزين اضربوا سوريا بعد صدام
وقالوا لبوش يدخل على سوريا القى عملوا
قانون محاسبه سوريا وسوريا
اعلاميا فرض عقوبات اقتصاديه وسياسيه
وديبلوماسيه على رموز النظام كل فقره
الشرعيه في كل شيء وبالتالي لا لا احد
يستطيع ان يقول كلمه واحده ان الولايات
المتحده او حتى نظام اوباما دعم بشار او
يريد بشار او غير ذلك من بشار فبالتالي
بشار
بالنسبه لامريكا وانا اقول كمحلل بالنسبه
لامريكا هو فاقد الشرعيه تماما والصراع
ليس على بشار وعلى فكره بعض الناس بتصور
انه اه اه اه الروس حتى كمان عزم بشار لا
الروس ولا الايرانيين ولا الامريكان يهمهم
مساله
استمرار بشار بل على العكس الامريكي روس
قالوا لامريكا في الفتره الاخيره انتم
عاوزين ايه قالوا لهم عاوزين بشريا مش
قالوا لهم اشار دخلوا في لعبه الكيماوي
لحد مصير
المده بتعطوا واحد بداله بدل ان تسقط
سوريا كلها و يسقطوا النظام احنا مسؤولين
عن انه نشرها يمشي حتى الروس قالوا
للامريكان ها الشركه بشار ال الايرانيين
الان على استعداد ان يتخلوا عن بشار في
مقابل التفاهمات النوويه فبالتالي لا احد
يريد بشار ولا احد يدافع عن بشار ولكن كل
الناس تدافع عن المصالح بتاعتها وان بشار
الا هو القادر على حاليا في هذه الفتره
حتى لا ينظر كل شيء وتتحول سوريا الى دوله
فاشله كامله تنهار كل شيء في المنطقه
والعلاقات مع هذه الدول ومصالحها دعنا
نتخلص
تدريجيا حتى نجد بديلا له من داخل نظام
ولا تنهار سوريا اما ما قدمته امريكا
للسوريين
الشعب السويدي خليني بس دقيقه قبل ان اتي
الى ما قدمته هذه نقطه مهمه جدا تاتيك
اليها كيف ترى الدكتور الرجل يحكي منطق
يعني كمان الرجل يقول انه كيف يعني البعض
بالمعارضه يصورون النظام السوري على انه
حبيب امريكا وانه يعني يلعب مع امريكا تحت
الطاوله وانه كذا وكذا طيب يا اخي لكن اذا
نظرنا كما يقول له قانون محاسبه سوريا
العقوبات المفروضه على هذا النظام منذ زمن
طويل عقوبات اقتصاديه عقبه
لا يستطيع ان يشتري محرك طائره يعني كان
يغير محرك طائره من طائره الى اخرى كي
يسافر لان الامريكان يمنعون عنه كل شيء
وتاتي وتقول انه امريكا تحمل نظام امريكا
كذا هذا الكلام غير صحيح
واقول لك اليوم اليوم اوباما هل سمعت
التصريحات ومجلس الجمعيه العامه قويه جدا
قال من يعتقد ان بشار الاسد المستقبل في
سوريا مغفل هذا النظام انتهى يا ايران يا
روسيا بشار الاسد انتهى ولن نقبل به وهذا
الرئيس الامريكي يحكي هذا الكلام ايضا
يعني
نستدل بشار الاسد بنسخه اخرى عن بشار
الاسد مع الحفاظ على النظام وكانه القضيه
قضيه واحد رجل واحد يعني هذا النظام كله
مركب تركيبه معينه هذا النظام كله هو
المسؤول ليس فقط شخص بشار المحاكم على
الشعب السوري بيقولوا لا فقط شرعيته
يتعاملوا معه يتصلوا فيه بالتلفون وياخذوا
على جنيف ويعطوهم ويقولوا انه بدي بقي
بالسلطه ويقولوا ان النظام هو الحامي
البلد راح النظام بتروح البلد هذا النظام
هو الذي دمر البلد هذا النظام هو الذي دمر
من سوريا هذا النظام العام المشكله
بالمجتمع السوري عمل مشكله عمل مشكله
طائفيه خطيره جدا اخر بالمنطقه هذا النظام
الذي يجب ان يحاسب بكافه رموزه واركانه مش
معقول انا اختصار شغله بشار الاسد وجيده
ولا جيب نعم ه ونجيب ابن شريكه بنشر يكون
يحكم لا لا يحكم سوريا او رئيس الاركان
السابق هذا الكلام مو صح هذا الكلام من
يمشي الشعب السوري يجب ان يرحل مين مين
بدو رحله ان تعطيه كل الفرصه الامن
الامريكان تركوا ستعمل الكيماوي وتركوا
يستعمل اسكت وقبل الطيران وقبل الطيران
تركوا يستعمل الجيش واخر شيء بتتذكر يجب
ارجى واحده وقف نظام الرعب كانوا ممكن
يوقفوا النظام عند اول طلقه انما بدو
الامريكان ما بدو وقت اللي انت تقول انه
الامريكان هم الذين يدفعون النظام باتجاه
بالتدمير وقت اللي ال خط احمر الكيماوي
معنات كل ما قبل بكيماوي اخضر هذا معناتها
الشارع قتل الشعب السوري من هون نحنا
بنقول انه ما نشر عن القتل قتل الش الشعب
السوري وامريكا هو النظام العالمي هو
التفاهمات اللي عم يحكي عم يحكي عليها نحن
تلقينا رساله الكراهيه رساله كراهيه
سيحفظها الشعب السوري ميت سنه امريكا من
امريكا هذه الرساله كراهيه رساله حقد
ستنعكس تغذي الخيال الارهابيين والمتطرفين
الذي سنه وستشرع يعملون هذه الرساله
الخاطئه لارتكاب اليوم المجتمع اللي بدو
يحس المواطن السوري حسبه معاناته ونبدا
يحس فيه يدعي بيحكوا بيحكوا كلام انه يعني
الامور هيك ونريد في النهايه هذا الانسان
يقتل كل يوم شو تعطي يونيو يعني يعني تسمح
بقتل مائه الف ثاني تسمح بتدمير والناس لا
يشبه بالشوارع وجزء الكلام وهيدي كل
من الناس المشردين تفكير لا ترجع يعني
واحد من الناس اللي انا بالد يموت بسوريا
ما بدي شيء انا بدي موت بسوريا يا اخي انا
بدي افهم ببلدي هذا المطلب بقول لك انا
بدي
مقود اخذوا النظام مائه الف انسان اخذها
النظام وقتلوا ما حد ما حدا بيجيب سيرتها
الناس كل هيدي الموضوع ما بتشوف وبتروح
بتشوف لانه قال قال قال انه الشرعي وغير
شرعيه
يتعامل معه كرئيس الشرعي ويريد نحن
المعارضه ان نذهب الى جنيف نجلس مع وفد
معه ونعيد انتاج الدوله السوريه يعني
النظام السابق بعدين هذا
الجهاد الكلام اللي بالامكان والروس ولن
يمر لن يمر باي طريقه لن يمر على دمنا لن
يمر ومن يفوز هذا النظام هو الشريك سيحقق
مش خليل انت تقول انه اه يعني امريكا تريد
ان تحافظ على سوريا ولا تريد المنطقه وما
بعرف شو صح ولا لا تريد ان تحافظ على
سوريا لكن نحن لو نظرنا انت لو استمعت الى
اللقاء الذي اجراه الرئيس السوري مع صحيفه
التايمز البريطانيه قبل حوالي سنه قال
بالحرف الواحد ان سوريا تقع على فارق
زلزلي ولو تحرك هذا الفلك لا احترقت
المنطقه باكملها لو نظرنا الان لوجدنا ان
الكلام الذي قاله الاسد في ذلك الوقت يحدث
يحدث تركيه على كف عفريت لبنان على كف
عفريت الاردن على كف عفريت العراق على كف
عفريت المنطقه باكملها تتفتت بسبب
اللاجئين بسبب النار بسبب الحدود
واضاف الفوضى هلاك وليس خلاقه في كل
المنطقه سوريا تدمرت سوريا تدمرت انت تقول
يريد ان يحافظ على سوريا ماذا بقي من
سوريا كي يحافظ عليها بالعكس الامريكان هم
الذين يدفعون هذا النظام كي يدمر المزيد
والمزيد على مقولات نابليون اذا رايت عدوك
يدمر نفسه ولا تقاطعه وجيد كله اوباما
اوباما مقصود جدا والخراب الذي يعملوا
بشار الاسد في المنطقه لم يعد شعار بشار
الاسد الاسد او نحرق البلد الاسد او نحرق
المنطقه المنطقه تحترق واوباما فقد شرعيته
الكلام مع السوريين و عم يضحكوا عليه
يقولوا له اوباما العالم كله عم بيضحك
عليه صار
الامريكان ننجح اذا كانت المنطقه تصفي
نفسها بنفسها بعيدا عن الامريكان وبعيد عن
ايدي الامريكان عن طريق اه الصراع ما بين
الانظمه القادمه وما بين النظام الاخواني
اللي هو الاخوان المسلمين
موضوع امريكا امريكا الخراب الذي يحصل
منطقه
وخاصه في سوريا
هو كل الناس دي الوقتي دقيقه جدا جدا من
امريكا علشان مساله انهم مضرب وسوريا مضر
بوش سوريا اه اه ال ال ال امريكا لما راحت
العراق وراحت افغانستان قالت انا اعتمد
على الماده واحد وخمسين من ميثاق الامم
المتحده ان انا اعتدى على ودون اعداءه
ولازم اضرابهم والسهم في ضرب ودول احتضن
القاعده ولازم ضرب الدولي الان كيف تذهب
امريكا الى اه الى سوريا خارج القانون
الدولي وخارج ميثاق الامم المتحده وخارج
تحالف الراغبين حتى مفيش تحالف راغبين حتى
في في في العراق كان في حاجه تحالف
الراغبين وخارج التحالف الرغبه
نقطه مهمه جدا مجدى مجدى لا تحاول ان يعني
مجدي انا بسالك سؤال عندما ذهبت امريكا
الى العراق كان كل مبنيه على الكذب بشهاده
الرئيس بوش حتى الرئيس بوش في مكتبه واحد
قالوا قالوا وين اسلحه الدمار الشامل
العراقيه قالوا خليك خليك شويه فتح الدوره
وقال لهم الموجود عليه يعني لكن في اسلحه
ولا ذهبت الى العراق على اساس الان في
سوريا هناك جرائم ضد الانسانيه
لاول مره في القرن الحادي والعشرين يستخدم
يستخدم الكيماوي يستخدم الكيماوي هذا هو
السؤال اين مسؤوليه امريكا لا احد يريد من
امريكا انت تحتل سوريا لكن الامريكي
نقطه
انه كل سوريا عشر مليون مشرف عشر مليون
مشرد بلد مدمر المنطقه على كافيه وامريكا
لم تعد مهتمه الا بالكيماوي عندنا سلموا
من ال كما وانتهت اللحظه كلها معقوله هذا
هذا السقوط الاخلاقي كل ازمه سوريا
لا
يا سيدي اسمح لي بس اسمع
الاخر او الحاجه يا صديقي او الحاجه
جزء من مشكله تحرك امريكا هي مشكلتها في
العراق لان فعلا التضخم ان هناك مشكله
خداعيه للشعب الامريكي في العراق
والكونغرس الان لا يمكن ان يذهب الى سوريا
بعد هذه التكاليف الباهظه في العراق وبعد
هذا الخداع الكبير الذي حدث في العراق
وكلنا كنا مؤيدين الخضار العراق وبعد ذلك
قلنا لا عندما انكشفت اللعبه وان كشفت
الكذبه وبالتالي انا كنت من اكثر مؤيدين
على ان تذهب امريكا للعراق البشر
الديمقراطيه في العراق ومنها الى الشرق
الاوسط ولكن طلع ان هذه المساله لعب
لسببين السبب الاول ان القائمه على كذبه
ثانيا ان العرب في المنطقه كلهم عطلوا
مشروع اه اجنده الديمقراطيه اللي جورج بوش
وبالتالي وبالتالي ذهاب امريكا الى سوريا
حاليا من اصعب الامور على الراي العام
الامريكي والاوروبي وعلى المشرعين في
امريكا واوروبا من ال من ال ال المفارقات
العجيبه ان
وبطريرك روسيا لكل يونان بطريرك الاقباط
ينادي
لا اريد ان
واحده
اولا ب باختصار اولا ما ضرب الكم او حتى
اللحظه لا توجد اه اه جازما بان
اشار الى ضرب ما ممكن ممكن تركيا تكون
ضربه
ممكن اي دوله اي مخابرات دوله
احنا لا نعرف
نعم ضرب الشعب الكيماوي لكن من ضربه
الاداره الامريكيه
الف وخمسمائه واحد بضرب عشرات الالاف
بالقوه الامريكيه
ثاني جميل خليك خليك حقيقه كيف ترد على
هذا الكلام يعني يعني انتم انتم ال الرجل
يقول هناك مزاج عالمي امريكا ليست امريكا
السابقه امريكا تفكر بحكمه يعني انتم
لماذا مثل ما قال يعني مشان الف وخمسمائه
انا بدي البلد يعني البلد يعني فوق شعبه
يعني زيد الخرائط يعني
بالموضوع يعني
قامت الثوره السوريه الثوره السلميه وتلك
للنظام لكي يجمعها وكان فيه تفاهم تفاهم
بين دول المنطقه وبين الروس الامريكان على
احتواء الربيع العربيه وقتله في سوريا
وامريكا الشريك في هذا التفاهم وامريكا
اعطت الاسد 2014 تفاهم مع روسيا هذا
الكلام اللي صار وتحولت هذه الثوره الى
الثوره السلميه الى ثوره مسلحه نتيجه
القتل نتيجه القتله على عيون الامريكان
وعلى عيون كل الناس ل حتى وصلت لمرحله
كل الناس المتطرفين تشارك بعدما ضعف
المريض وصل للموت فوتوا على عمليات لا
يموت تحت العمليه المقصود كان هو استنزاف
قوى المنطقه قتل الربيع العربي كل الناس
ساعدونا حتى يدرون بيعطونا مساعدات مثل
الخمر ضرره اكثر من نفعه كلهم حتى
الاصدقاء حتى الاشقاء شايف كيف بدهم
يخربوا
بدنا شعوبهم انه ما لازم تصير الثورات
الامريكان يجب ان يقتلوا حريه ليس للنقطه
العربيه ليش بدهن يقتلوا تقدم سوريا
والمنطقه سوريه انتقلت هذه القاطره
للمنطقه سوريا بتمشي لبنان بتمشي الاردن
في العراق اذن اذا مهدت هذه المنطقه على
دوله ديمقراطيه مدنيه ونجحت الثوره
السوريه سيكون المشروع الامريكي كله في
خطر وبالتالي المشروع الامريكي المتمثل
بالخط الصهيوني الذي يحكم منطقه وبالتالي
اسرائيل بدات شرعي نفسه لتقسيم هذه
المنطقه دويلات مثلها
التقسيم للاسف الامريكان يروا المنطقه
بعدما الدار الاسرائيليه يروا المنطقه
بالنظام الاسرائيلي ويروا شعوب المنطقه
كشعوب معاديه ما بيشوف والاطفال والنساء
والشعوب تريد الحضاره ولا بيشوفوا الناس
بدها تعيشوا بدها تكون شريكه في العالم
بيشوفوها اعداء يجب ان تستهلك قواها هني
كانوا كثير مبسوطين واتفاق حسن نصر الله
على سوريا وقت الفوز استهلكوا قبل المنطقه
و هني موجودين كثيرون عم يجوا المجاهدين
لهون من شان يستهلك وايضا في المنطقه
بيقولوا متطرف ضد ضد متطرفه يحولوا سوريا
للصراع لتدمير سوريا امريكا امريكا
واسرائيل وعملاء وروسيا والى اخره هؤلاء
هم الارهابيين الحقيقيين
هؤلاء هم الذين صنعوا الارهاب الذين
ابادوا الشعب السوري ودمروا سوريا ودمروا
مستقبلها لكنها لن تمر هذه الجريمه لن تمر
هذه جريمه متكامله لدرجه انه بينكر واه
يعني وقت الانسان وصل الى مرحله
بيكون اكتملت جريمته
استعمل الكيماوي مين استعمل كلمه اللي
عندها بدليل ما عندي دليل انت عندك يعني
ما نستطيع اليوم ان يشكك بال بال هولوكوست
بالمحرقه اليهوديه بيفوت بيفوت على ال على
على على المحكمه اليوم كل الناس بتشكك
الشعب السوري ما نجح ما في مائتين الف
انسان في مليون موجه في مليونين بيت
الدمار هذا الكلام بعيد التشكيك بمعاناه
الناس نعيد هذا بيدفع عن التطرف هذا
الكلام مش مقبول يعني التطرف القادم في
المنطقه سبب اوباما والسياسه الامريكيه
امريكا هي المسؤول الاول والاخير عن
التطرف الاسلامي وهي التي صنعت الجهل
والديكتاتوريه والفساد في المنطقه الذي
خلق الارضيه ل هذا التصرف انا اتهم
الاداره الامريكيه بدعم التطرف في المنطقه
وليس بمحاربته
عم يقول شعبه انه هو عم يحارب التطرف فهو
بالعكس تماما اوباما على شعبه يقول للشعب
وانا عم نحارب التطرف وهو الذي يخلق اعداء
امريكا والعداء لامريكا والعداء الاهم من
امريكا القيم الحضاره هو عمل الفتنه
الطائفيه وعم بيخلق المشاكل كلها على
الارض اللي عملوه بالثورات العربيه معروف
من مصر وغيرها وغيرها وغيرها لكي يعودوا
الى نظام الاستبداد والاستبداد بيعرفوا
تماما انه هو اللي ولا اقول ولاده التخلف
والولد التطرف وبالتالي هم يعيدوا انتاج
منطقه مدمره خليك شويه سيد اه مجدي هذا
الكلام يعني يقول لك البعض يتساءل او بعض
السوريين يتساءلون يعني كيف تتوقعون من
الاداره الامريكيه ان تساعد النظام السوري
وهو اكبر حامي لاسرائيل يعني كيف تريدون
من ان نقضي على حامي اسرائيل انت تعلم
ويقول الاخ هذا ليس كلامي يقول لك انه
امريكا تنظر الى كل المنطقه بالعيون
الاسرائيليه ولنا بالمنظار الاسرائيلي من
مصلحه ليس من مصلحه اسرائيل باي حال من
الاحوال ان تكون محاطه بديمقراطيه لانه
افضل افضل حل اسرائيل ان تكون محطه
بدكتاتوريات بطواغيت لجنرالات يقتلون
شعبهم يدرسون شعبهم يدرسون الحريه يدرسون
التقدم يدرسون النهضه ماذا تريد اسرائيل
اكثر يعني وجدت في النظام السوري اربعين
سنه وهو يدوس الانسان السوري على اقل كلمه
نظام يصبح البلد نظام دمر البلد ان هناك
الجيش ان هكذا امريكا اللي كان هذا بهذا
روعه حتى لو شعروا الاجله على سوريا لن
يخرج بنفس الطريقه في ال عشان اروح هذا
المخرج هيك يقول لك الرجل كيف ترد عليه
دعني ارد على عده نقاط او لهم النقطه اللي
انت اثرتها موضوع اسرائيل على فكره
الاسرائيليه الاسرائيليون بعد تماما عن
الموضوع ده تماما منذ ان قامت ثوره
منذ ان قامت الانتفاضه السوريه لاننا نهار
جعل هذه المصطلحات بعد كده منذ ان قامت
هذه الانتفاضه وال ال الاسرائيليون بعدين
وبيشوفوا دوله هم اه اه تمثل عداء لهما
بتخرب من الداخل وسوق بيتفرجوا لكن لما
جات امريكا
قررت ضرب اه اه سوريا او او اعلنت عن ذلك
اسرائيل اه كل الاسرائيليين بعدوا في
البدايه لفتره بسبب الموضوع وفي الاخر
كلهم قالوا ضرب يعني الراي العام
الاسرائيلي في الداخل والخارج كان يكون
قدره لكي تضرب محور حزب الله وتمنع عنه ال
ال المعونات وبالتالي مساله اسرائيل دي
جانبيه سنويه جدا في موضوع سوريا اللي انت
مش عارفين تشوفوه انه موضوع سوريا اسرائيل
فيها ماشيه جدا لان اسرائيل قويه بما فيه
الكفايه
وان القوه التي حولها
الجيش العراقي الدمار جيش اه اه سوريا
انتهت سوريا انتهت كدوله امام صرفه مجهوله
في مشاكلها فلا يوجد التحدي الاسرائيلي
لكي تدخل في هذه اللعبه
ان تدين نفسها مجدي ان تدين نفسها هذا ما
اقول هناك يعني امريكا واسرائيل اخذت هذا
الموقف اللامبالي على مبدا اذا رايت عدوك
يدمر نفسه فلا تقاطع يعني من مصلحه امريكا
ومن مصلحه اسرائيل ان ينفك الجيش السوري
من مصلحه اسرائيل ان تدمر سوريا من مصلحه
اسرائيل ان تعود سوريا خمسين سنه الى
الوراء وامريكا بتقول لي شو هذا النظام
ليس امام وتدمير على عشره اشهر في تدمير
دمارا توفير كان المدينه وطوقت
هذا هذه التهم الموجهه لامريكا انا اقول
لك ارد عليك
ارد عليك رد عليك من مصلحه اسرائيل نعم من
مصلحه اسرائيل الدول
اما صحتها كدا كدا صحوا من منظور الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي صحيح ولكن الموضوع
الامريكي ابعد من كده بكثير الموضوع
الامريكي هو اللي خلا انتفاضات الربيع
العربي انا على مدى ثلاث سنوات وكنت من
اكثر المؤيدين ل لما يسمى الربيع العربي
ولما تسمى الانتخابات الديمقراطيه ولكن
الان اكتشفت اللاعب انها لعبه مباره من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان الربيع
العربي ما يسمى بالثوره السوريه هذه
المصطلحات لا في ربيع عربي وضع ديمقراطي
ولا ربيع اه مواطن يعني ام
يعني امريكا
تاكيد اكمل بس نعم امريكا ورات امريكا
ورات لان امريكا كانت تريد بعد ان فشل
مشروع نشر الديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط
واجنده الديمقراطيه انتقلت الى الخطه اه
الخطه هي ان يسكن الاسلاميين يسيطروا على
الشرق الاوسط الاخوان المسلمين يدير الشرق
الاوسط ويلم والارهابيين في العالم في عقر
دارهم ان يرجع الارهابيون الى بلادهم عن
طريق حكم الاسلاميين انفسهم وكانت قطر
وكانت اردوغان
القائدين لهذه العمليه وبالتالي الان ترى
ان هذه العمليه فشلت ايضا فشل البحث انها
تعترف المشروع في سوريا
المشكله نقطه مهمه
سيد سيد كمان انتم تقولون امريكا وامريكا
ومن يا اخي الرجل يقول لك انه السي اي ايه
تلعب دورا كبيرا حتى في الثوره السوريه
السي اي ايه موجوده على الحدود التركيه
تدير كم وتدير المعارضه وتدير ال ما
يسمونه بالحوار وتدير كذا يعني
الاسلحه التي يحصل عليها الثوار السوريون
هل كانت وصلت اليهم لولا غض الطرف
الامريكي على الاقل لولا المباركه
الامريكيه لماذا يعني ب تاكلوا من الصحه
والتوسع في يعني انا بدي اقول لك شغله
لانه امريكا ستعمل الثوره بالدعاء باسم
احسن تعمل ها الحلقه اللي بعد سنه ونصف
يعني كيف امريكا عملتها الثورات وما حسن
تتحرر حلب مع مع يعني انت شفت كيف صارت
الثوره وكيف اندلعت وامور عفويه وليست
هكذا وايضا السلاح قسم كبير من السلاح كان
موجود بسوريا وكان عند الشعب السوري القسم
اخذوه من الجيش السوريه وبالتالي هنا
يديروا لعبه ان سلاح على الشكل التالي نحن
لا نريد للثوره ان تهزم لحد الطرف الثاني
يتورط لحتى يستمر الصراع لكن من وازن
اللعبه
بيفوت من السلاح الانتصار
لا يريدوا يعني هم يدعمون ليش لحتى نضع في
المحور الايراني ما عم يدعمونا حتى ننتصر
والدول العربيه تدعمنا ضد ايران مشان
ديمقراطيه وبالتالي بيعطوا سلاح معين
وذخيره معينه بحيث انت ما تم وتبقى
المعركه حاميه ولا تنتهي يعني لا سلاح
يحسم معركه
اذا من يدير اللعبه يديروا لعبه شيء وهني
حركوا
بنفس الوقت يقول لك الرجل يعني كيف تريد
من امريكا ان تسلح الارهابيين الذين قتلوا
بعقل ادارها يعني هذه نقطه مهمه قال قال
مجمل في البدايه واعود الان يعني بما ان
طيب يعني يقول لك كيف تريد من امريكا
حاميه الديمقراطيه ان تستبدل الظالم
بالظلام مثلا تدعم الارهابيين تدعم بدك
ياها
اللي اللي خلى السوريين يضطر بالثوره مثلا
كيف ترد يعني موضوع موضوع التطرف ونتيجه
سنتين ونصف السنه كان للثوره السوريه وراح
فرض على حماس
السفير الامريكي واللي يدبروا الدوحه هو
علي حبيب يعني م وزير وزير الدفاع السابق
الروح او شافوه وشافوا وبناء عليه نصح
والحبيب ان لا يتدخل عسكريه
الحديد مرضيه تدخل قالوا
اللي عم يدبروا يجيبوه مره ثانيه يعني هن
عم يحاولوا يلعبوا عم بيحاولوا يديروا
اللعبه عم بيحاولوا يفرضوا معارضه في
الخارج
على طريقه الشغل عم بيحاول يج رونالدو له
مكونات
امريكا فرضت علينا انه نحنا نوقع اتفاقيه
نقول بان الشعب السوري مش واحد اكثر من
الشعب انه دوله اتحاديه بين امريكا بالقوه
و بالنفوذ واجوا السفراء قعدوا فقرتنا
وقالوا بتكون تمشوا المشروع والمشروع ما
مشي باغلبيه كبيره في اغلبيه عاديه جدا
وهذا ما بيصير لان هذا الدستور بلد وقال
وهذا المشروع بدنا اياها وانا اكثر من
مسؤول اتصل فيه اللي هي بدنا شيء ليش
بتمشيه لماذا اليوم تطرح قضيه الشعب
السوري متعدد لماذا لانه الامريكيه طبعا
فاتوا من بوابه القضيه الكرديه وهي قضيه
حق لانه دوله علويه ولا يشرع انه دولها
الثانيه
للاسف استخدموا القضيه الكرديه بالمكان
الغلط انا بلوم هنا كثيره اخوتنا الاكراد
بهذا المشروع هذا المشروع اللي مر على
الائتلاف مشروع خطير جدا سيؤدي بكره
النفوذ الغربي الناس اللي فاتت تصويت سري
ما يصوتوا وفرضوا بالضغوط وبعدين السفراء
برا لحتى مر مشروع وهذا المشروع لن يمر
لانه هذا المشروع سيؤدي الى سوريا دوله
مكونات الى دوله الى دوله الطائف وبالتالي
سيخلق صراع طويل ومد يد وسيخلق دوله فاشله
اسرائيل الى موضوع الطريقه العراقيه
واللبنانيه يريدون استنساخ هذا النموذج
بالقوه وان ترك وسوريا تنهار ليقولوا
سوريا دوله فاشله وجنيف بوابه التقسيم
وبكره بتشوفه والشعب السوري يحكم عليه
جنيف بوابه دوله محاصصه ودوله التقسيم
والقضيه الكرديه لن تحل بهذه الطريقه
وبيعطوا شيء من الاكراد اللي اللي فاتوا
فيه من باب الاكراد لا يعطوا للعلويين
لحتى يضعفوا سوريا يضمنوا انه سوريا تبقى
ضعيفه وتبقى تحت السيطره مصلحه والا لما
المصلحه الاسرائيلي والاخطر من ذلك ان
تبقى مرهونه اقتصاديا وهو من الخضر الثاني
راح يفوتوا بشركات يستعملوا بلد اقتصاديا
وبالتالي اعادوا نفوذهم هذه هي امريكا
الصديقه اذا هيك الصديق بيساوي فالعدو شو
بيساوي
اه خليل اذا كان الصديق الامريكي فعل
بسوريا كل ما فعل يعني وهذا يعود بنا الى
موضوع الفيتو البعض يقول انه يعني الفيتو
الروسي اللي الذي استخدم في مجلس الامن
يعني من من من اجل النظام السوري يقول
البعض ال الناس اللي موجودين هناك عندما
كان المندوب الروسي يرفع ايدو الفيتو كان
المسؤولين الامريكان مبسوطين يعني نسمع
انه هم الذين كانوا يدفعون الروس بهذا
الاتجاه لانهم لا يريدون حلا يريدون ان
تصل سوريا الى ما وصلت اليه الان يعني حتى
الفيتو الروسي كان بدعم و مباركه امريكيه
روس اه امريكا الان تريد ان تقسم سوريا
وماشي بهذا الاتجاه ماذا تقول له هذا رجل
من اهم المعارضين السوريين
يعني انا يعني اولا اه هذا الرجل اللي انا
متعاطف مع او متعاطف ما حدث وفي سوريا
وانا معه وانا معه ضد الاستبداد ومع
الديمقراطيه وحياته كلها مكرسه من اجل
الديمقراطيه
امريكا الوقت
عشر سنوات
ما يقوله الان عن الامريكان انا
ذلك وانا معه قلبا وقالبا وانا مع
الديمقراطيه قلبا وقالبا مع تطلعات الشعوب
لكن المساله يا سيدي الوقت ما بيمشي لعبه
شعوب الشعوب ما بدوش حاجه اللعبه كلها
خارجيه
هذا هو المشكله اللي خلتنا محبطين جدا ان
ما فيش امل للديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط
انا بقولها لك لا يوجد امل الديمقراطيه في
الشرق الاوسط هي الخيارات كلها خيارات حول
الاستبدال وشكل ال استبدال استبدال الديني
والاستبداد رجعي والاستبدال
بهذا الاتجاه
قال الرجل الذي يمنع الاتجاه الاستبداد
الديني والاستبداد باتجاه التطرف هي
امريكا هي امريكا الان سياسات امريكا هي
التي تدفع السوريين الى التطرف تدفعهم الى
داعش والى وما بعرف شو يا امريكا لو تدخل
ال ال من الانساني لما وصلت الامور الى
هذا الحد لو على الاقل
نعم لا لا لا الشكل الشكل او لسببين السبب
الاول اني انا واثق شريكه موجود معاك على
ان امريكا نعم هي من اضلاع صناعه الظاهره
الاسلاميه في العالم ام امريكا ومصر
والسعوديه وايران وايران ودخلت عليهم على
الخط قطر غذاء الجهاد الاسلامي القاعده
صناعه مخابراتيه انا بقول لك ومنها امريكا
وبالتالي هذه ليست ليست هذه اصبحت معلومه
معروفه لكن المشكله الاساسيه ان امريكا
طرقت سوريا وحلفائها يعني انا
يعني ان تدين امريكا انه امريكا اتت ب
هؤلاء الارهابيين سوريا يخربوا سوريا
انا دقيق حلفائها
المشروع الاساسي
المشروع
الاسلاميه
اسمعني اسمعني
المشروع الاساسي اللي هو اللي هو حكم
الاسلاميين للمنطقه هو مشروع امريكي
وهم الذين
هذه نقطه مهمه
الديمقراطيه لم توجد في اوروبا قبل خمسين
سنه الديمقراطيه جديده جديده اوروبا نحنا
شعب يريد الديمقراطيه ولن يكون في سوريا
الا دوله مدنيه واللي بيفكر انه هاي
الظاهره
الان تعيش عيشه مضاده التاريخ ومضاده
للواقع المضاده نفسها
انا بتمنى انه الشعب السوري طبعا شان
الديمقراطيه ولن تكون ديمقراطيه بس بس
نقاط كثيره البعض يقول وقال الرجل
الامريكي تبحث عن مصلحتها وكل دول العالم
تبحث عن مصلحتها وانت تعلم ان الدول ليست
جمعيات خيريه ولا سيارات اسعاف طيب انتم
النظام السوري النظام السوري احد
المسؤولين الامريكيين الكبار قال سالوه
ذات مره ما رايك بالاعلام السوري الذي
يحرك ضد امريكا دائما فقال لهم نحن لا
يهمنا ما يقوله النظام السوري نحن يهمنا
ما يفعله النظام السوري لنا نحن نطلب من
النظام السوري ان ينفذ لنا قضيه بنسبه
اربعين بالمائه ثاني يوم يطلعنا بنفسه اهم
مائتين واربعين بالمائه نظام مستعد ان
يتنازل يعني حتى الامريكان بالامس عندما
شاهدوا التقارير اللي بعثها عن الكيماوي
النظام السوري على العمل مشكل هذا ما كان
عندنا عارفين اعطاهم لقدام بلاوي لقدام
لقدام زياده انت معارضين انت تعرف
بالمنطقه العربيه الاكثر تحكما طول انتم ك
معارضين سوريين ماذا لديكم ان تقدم
والامنيه طلبت من كون الامريكان تسلم
الكيماوي رفضتم النظام عطا ها الكم او يا
اخي صالح ماذا لديكم انتم زمان النظام سلم
مفاعل الكبرى طبعا مفاعلها النووي اللي
كان بعد محمد سليمان و سرب المعلومه الى
للامريكان الامنيه ويوم الايرانيين قالوا
له انه ليش صار عندك ام الخيانه فهذا يعني
يعني السوري ما بامر من بشر سلم بامر من
بشار الاسد
وسلمت لكي لكي يبقى في السلطه انا عم قول
لك شغله مهمه كثير مصلحه امريكا بالسلام
والاستقرار والتقدم
على انه هذا لديكم ان تقدم
انت تقول لانه نظام سلم المفاعل النووي
النووي
دول الفين وسبعه
وقتل الرجل الاساس انه منذ شهر الاستاذ
اللي بعده
وقتلوا يوم اللي كان رايح على على ايران
لانه كان ممنوع يروح على ايران قبل ما
يدخل من الخيانه والايرانيين بيعرفوا
بيعرفوا ان هذا النظام بيسلم كل شيء ولو
الامريكان بدهم انه شيء بياخذوا انا بدي
اقول انه امريكا امريكا المفروض تكون
حامله الحضاره حامله القيم الانسانيه
مشكور مخرب بالعالم امريكا دوله عظمى
عظيمه ب باخلاقه وبقيام هامش عظيمه بقوتها
ولا عظيمه بخمسه لماذا امريكا تريد تدمير
تدمير المنطقه السبب الوحيد هو الاداره
الاسرائيليه امريكا الى مصلحه بثلاثمائه
مليون الانسان نحن شريك مكمل لسنا عدو
تشوفونا من
بس عم نطلب من هناك يشوفون
يا اسلام هذا
الوقت يداهمنا مجدى خليل انت تقول لي في
البدايه انه امريكا فرحنا على النظام كذا
وحاصرت
وعملت كذا صحوا الان طيب وهذا من الفيسبوك
مهمه يقول لها النظام السوري يعين معارضيه
دائما بالعماله لامريكا وهو لم يترك خدمه
ال او قدمها لامريكا وقد وصف حسب تقرير
الاسيان المخابرات الامريكيه وصفته السي
اي ايه في عام 2012 هذا الكلام ليس لهم
ولا بعرف شو صحته وصفت النظام السوري
بالعميل النشاط بالعميل النشاط يعني من
جهه بتقولوا انه امريكا ضد النظام وكذا
الوثائق النظام العميل العميل النشر
يتحدثون عن مبارك وقلت الاستراتيجي
الاستراتيجي راح بعد اسبوعين الاسرائيليه
موجودون فانت كيف
الان هناك امريكي ايراني سوري لتسليم
المنطقه الى ايران ماذا تقول لهم يعني
الغزل الامريكي الايراني اصبح مكشوفه
للجميع امبارح خففوا العقوبات عن ايران
قال بحجه الروحاني اتصل باليهود وهنا هم
في عيد الغفران وما حدا شباب الخبر لعبه
مكشوفه بين النظام السوري والايرانيين
والامريكان على عينك يا تاجر
واسرائيل وروسيا ماذا تقول لهم انما
العلاقه
طيب
طيب اسمح اول حاجه في في منطقه المخابرات
اسم العميل المتوافق العميل المتوافق
بمعنى ان هذا الشخص ممكن يكون ب يخدم
المصالح الاستراتيجيه للدوله العظمى رغم
انه ليس لها بغبائه يؤدي الى ذلك ولكن
امريكا مثلا الامم المتحده طالبت اكبر
نداء في تاريخ خمسه مليار دولار لمساعده
اللاجئين السوريين قدمت امريكا مليار
وثلاثمائه واربعين الف
وتتم اربعين اليوم
المعونات الانسانيه ماذا قدم العرب من ضمن
العرب ارهابيون قدم العرب ارهابيين
الشيوخ السعوديين
الوقت كلمه اخيره وكلمه اخيره يقول لك
العرب يقول لك امريكا من حقها ان تتم
مصالحات كلمه اخيره ماذا تريد تقول
للامريكان على ضوء بعد ان تركوا سوريا
الفين وخمسه وثمانون انه ينقذوا المنطقه
بمشروع الديمقراطي ولكنهم لاعبوا الطريق
بطريقه اخرى قلنا له المنطقه لحرب اهليه
اذا لم تدخلوا بشكل فاعل اجا اوباما الا
بالسياسه الامريكيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
مشاهدي الكرام لم يبق لنا الا شكرا لضيفنا
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من واشنطن مجدى خليل
وهنا في الاستقلال دكتور كما اللبناني
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]